potrebbe quasi sembrare un placement
questo prodotto pepper in italia non si
può comprare perché non la fanno quindi
non è un placement veda tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vigili siano zucca band è un gioco che
non sapevo se registrare o meno in sti
giorni poi l'ha fatto pd by allora ho
detto vabbè possiamo registrando
presenti basse tanto consiglio perfetto
l'avevano presentato quando sono andato
all'e3 di los angeles solo che non
sapevo se l'avrei fatto meno e alla fine
l'ho fatto per non saper io giuro e non
saprei come spiegare questo gioco è
proprio quando vi fumato una canna e
questo dà risultati non fumate sto
scherzando nella per dire io non l'ho
mai fatto cosa si sono fumati
caratteristiche
ok al branco che mi fa effetto e sono
questo fantastico beh sono esperti in
questi giochi si sapeva già da prima
raga non giocate a sta roba da ubriachi
per cortesia anzi non vi ho pregato e
propria passiamo messaggi positivi e una
dedizione non lo faccio mai come bianca
porca linda vacca tra ecco questo
messaggio positivo contributo fare lo
sapevo io
la ragazza è impossibile c'è un check
point e da qualche parte per cortesia
con una vita è aiuto
[Musica]
a posto cosa mica è sta roba regale c'è
il point esistono nei videogiochi fateli
maledizione però il problema non è come
non è anche difficile ok io la comunione
e la cresima due le fate bruciare con un
video per cortesia non da zero non da
zero no da zero tua madre il parziale ma
vi rendete conto quanto difficile
servite nei superm i tuoi e un tutorial
in confronto è ok
bravo grazie grazie grazie momento dove
sono messo un anno pro vinto 0 check
point poi c'è quanto non esistono
rispettiamo fa bene grazie molto già
prezzo di meno ma va bene mi fate capire
un attimo il senso di sta roba shop c'è
un software cioè merchandising veder
port cleanser forum non farmi vedere
l'emporio mettono le donne offerta ai
moniti li trovo dentro il gioco servono
per comprare le cose ma sono cose
permanenti o cosa spregio trademe
grinder ed asi quindi sono permanenti le
cose che compro venga comprato il range
che doveva essere lo sparo quello su più
livelli va bene posso andare qua ha
difficoltà a far scegliere con con
dentro il e livella la piacevole guardai
visto che sono una persona brava ai
videogiochi
la donna un tubero
quindi auto è un tutto lo aiuto è un
tubero gigante è mai questa abbiamo
fatto grosso aiuto aiuto aiuto che senza
eccesso l'ho patito troviamo ma è un
boss questa era madera ma io non ho
capito ma questo è presente un
deficiente quello sono quello io cosa
devo fare
ho battuto praga sono troppo forte
grazie
scusate un attimo ma il creatore di
questo gioco sono vegani
non so vi viene è una domanda così è per
caso ma quindi fammi capire io sono tre
vite per livello e non le trovo non me
le posso aumentare miss e io perdo tre
vite in tutto livello sono morto non c'è
poi per iniziare più che la zero wow
come far perdere la religione anche il
papa è però dei tre pareggi o se ti
sparo porca vacca quanto dura st carota
c'è la carota ten singh tra l'altro tra
l'altro non so se ve ne siete accorti ma
l'ho battuto prima un millesimo di
secondo prima che mi colpisse dopo tanto
così ed ero morto va bene il primo
tentativo regolano vinto quindi ma veri
cime noci me va bene non importa va bene
ragazzi andiamo avanti a fare chiuse
clip joint calamity regular cos'è questo
questo è un altro non pensa sia un altro
bossi un altro po ma basta ai boss
ma fatemi fare un livello basta ai boss
vabbè che possono cos'è una rana e la
madonna infatti incazzati city insieme
ai posso farlo ho capito allora lo scemo
è fortissima quest'arma raga aiuto aiuto
mi chiedeva ben non solo non so come ho
fatto a schivarli non fate domande ti
prego potrei sembrare anche forte ai
videogiochi dopo questa cosa ho fatto me
non è così
no no no non sbaglia
[Musica]
vabbè vabbè malaga ma stiamo scherzando
la cosa da una roba incredibile ma vero
mai visto gioco si aiuto quanta ansia
no dai porca vacca sito numero vicino
no mi centro semina devo farcela ma
ormai la questione di vita dicono
altrimenti dati sulle mutande ma libero
se n'è fatto uno li batte tutti e due o
devo batterli tutti e due e insaccati o
h vacca lo sta facendo
sarei magnate vabbè con sei diventato
cosa no non ci credo
cosa sta no va bene però non può essere
veramente così difficile me lo farei
fare tutto dai cheppallle avviato la
cosa ho fatto tre tris alla madonna cosa
aiuto aiuto
scusatemi rappresenta sta roba scusami
cosa era quanto veloce né giusto io lo
lascio di il joystick salva di quanti ne
vuoi di screenshot ti prego dai posta la
madonna basta ma io non me la devo
colpire la sua facilità
cosa avrà diverso ogni volta e va bene
se invece ci mancava solo diverso ogni
volta quanto incasinato questo
[Musica]
possiamo concludere ti prego non ce la
faccio più no non vincerà mai cervello e
ve lo garantisco non vincerò mai doma
potete infilo la dottor peppers i'm
trying filo mamma mia non ho mai più e
chi meno non ne frega niente quanto
prendono bene i gusti papera che
facciamo l'ultimo livello vediamo se
riesco a trovarne uno abbastanza rapido
tipo un albero questo c'è un boss non lo
faccio cm me ne vado non può essere un
bosco di fattive normale boss fanno cosa
no no no mi rifiuto io mi rifiuto di
fare starovic e ragazzine me ne vado
[Musica]
ma leva qualcosa questo attacco che fa c
era fermo e affermo io sono andato
addosso a lui era fermo io sono andato
addosso al lupo da una roba ma neanche
non fatemi andare per questo pomodoro
insulso lo sly klorane for it now è
abbastanza trani gianpi shooting vado
armato tra monete grassi e molto gentili
dammi un extra art amiche un cuore in
più ed ecco lo fa tanto tiene alla fine
a leggere bene allora scrupoli in più è
già tanta roba era perché c'è una moneta
qua chi è sto tizio stato non lo capisco
l'inglese milan decadente introdurre mi
fate fare un livello per favore a tipo
questo potrebbe essere un livello
speriamo di sì mausoleo uno è un boss
ciao ragazze non possono
[Musica]
non ho capito a devo evitare che i
fantasmini raggiungano ok ma che l'ha
capito e non muoiono e non muore cosa
devo fare ma non muore non muore proprio
giovedì non sta morendo
ogni prendi per stupido e che non sono
io ma di tele le cose porca era stato
qualche guardate un piano d'accio si
avvicinano tipo venerdì tocca fare il
suo lavoro prodotto ma devo fare così
all'infinito ci avrà alla fine stagione
posso prendere questa roba
cosa mi han dato gas innamorare thank
you for boys e vi prego prego
due sono i miei ma non lo so darmi casi
non mi fa tradurre per inglese che
faccia le figure tipo renzi è sbloccato
una tazza grazie a mi ha dato un breve
un bonus di mandato super a questo
mandato e nagy mila ragazzi
per adesso basta perché non ho spaccato
la tastiera non ancora perlomeno ed è
già un grande traguardo per ogni video
insieme aiuto a fatemi sapere se volete
ancora capelli perché è un gioco un po
strano lo capisco e non ho mai fatto
niente del genere
che non ho mai fatto nulla che ci si
avvicini anche soltanto fatemi sapere se
vi piace io con quello qui episodio come
il momento mi piace anche vari social
che mi dona descrizione dove si rischia
temi e noi ci vediamo un po
[Musica]